i met emily when we were um on our
respective tv shows she was doing great
job on bones i was over on castle
we got together and presented an award
at the emmys and i was a spectacular
lady and i just remember
always wanting to work with her and
finally getting that opportunity
and it being everything i hoped it would
be um
did you want to come in you're not a
serial killer are you
not that that wouldn't be the perfect
bookend to this morning from health
well i'm actually a police officer so
the truth is i'm i'm sworn to protect
you
me personally you especially
the idea that if you are going to be on
a cop show
there there might be a cultural
awakening at that same time and then all
of a sudden you'll find yourself in a
position
that you weren't planning on and that
you're not prepared for nor
trained for but here we are
in our present position
by virtue of our show it's not the first
cop show on tv so the our fresh take on
the police program is accuracy
what's it really like it's not a lone
wolf bending the rules to get the bad
guy that's actually not
true and that trope that we've been sold
is
right now is that borders on
it's entertainment but it's a bit of a
dangerous storyline as far as
[Music]
the disinformation of it so we strive
for a little bit of accuracy that was
our angle
just by virtue of that accuracy i find
that we are
more so a part of the conversation than
we are
a part of the problem where cesar no one
knows but sandra's definitely hunting
him
you know if we could get to him first we
might be able to flip him
use his anger against la fiera to
sabotage his old operation you are not
the first to think of that in fact a
task force has been dedicated to finding
him but if you think you can succeed
where they fail knock yourself out
yes sir well i mean certainly we learn
about our characters we invest in our
characters we we have our little
adventures we watch them
experience life but to
meet the sons the daughters the ex-wives
the mothers
that's i think where we start to learn a
great deal
about our characters their history their
where have they come from what has
created the person that we're meeting
now what have they overcome what have
they
what were their successes oh and smitty
will be your t.o today
sarge the kid only has a few days left
as a rookie i'm
of course letting him ride solo today
you are oh well i'm not
worth a shot you know a lot of people
are really worried about the title
this is this is a real concern for a lot
of people and to that i would just say
don't worry it's not a job description
it's just a metaphor
it's just
you